good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it's friday friday gonna get down on
friday
wow we worked so hard so long
we made it you guys it's friday i hope
everyone is rejoicing in this
sacred blessed day as much as we are it
freaks me out to think that there's a
generation of kids who might not know
that song
well that's why we're here at the
morning toast we're gonna sing it every
week
we're trying to recruit younger fans
educate the masses but
only so that they will know that song
it's a beautiful
real testament to the beauty that is
friday yeah to the beauty that is friday
today is a gloomy friday but it actually
matches my mood because i'm so excited
for this to be done for me to go home
and just read all day and like not feel
like
should i do something alfresco right um
that's not happening
and at the beginning of this week i
thought it was going to be a slow one i
really did but
as far as quarantine weeks go this is
kind of just chugged right along
you know it's been a fine week um except
i came to a major realization about
myself
which realizing things about yourself is
a really frightening
journey to go on yeah um and it's not
very often that i realize things about
myself like my physical appearance
because people like on the internet just
point it out and then i'm like oh yeah i
do do that like i do talk over my jackie
like
they let me know you know they let me
know but i watched our episode
from yesterday because i loved it i
thought it was yesterday's episode was
one of my favorites that we've done in a
while so i like got home got in bed
cuddled up with theo and we watched it
you said to my dog theo theo get over
here
quick reminder that in case you haven't
watched my comedy special yet you should
that's a perfect activity for this
weekend
yes okay so i'm laying in bed and i'm
watching myself
and i'm trying not to do the thing that
i like i realize that both when i'm
talking and when i'm listening
i blink literally so much
literally i couldn't i could not get
over when i'm listening to you i'm like
she's trying to communicate with me i'm
doing morse code
that's not morse code but it's not yes
it is no morse code is a tapping
no it's like eyebrows and lips i guess
if the person doing the morse code like
has something in his eye
no no jackie we've spoken about this on
the show before morse code is literally
this
sure but that's it okay okay that's it
um just you guys
might want to google that um so yeah i
realize have a blinking problem i don't
know maybe it's like dry eye i need to
get that medicine jennifer addison is
always chilling on the commercials but
it's just something i realized about
myself and now i'm like so
self-conscious i'm like trying
not to blink i'm like a deer something
i've realized about myself which people
have
called me out for and i recognize within
myself is my new
unattractive habit on this show
of saying um before during and after
i have something to say and so that's
something that i'm working on i don't
know where it came from i've never been
in umr
i do think that my um's have taken away
from some of my likes though i i realize
i just
do still say like me too um
but at least um
is something you can train yourself out
of how can i stop blinking
i don't know i feel like i'm doing it so
much now like i'm freaking out i've
never noticed it i'm not gonna lie i
literally looked like i was falling
asleep on this couch yesterday i'm like
i can't believe nobody's pointed out
before because people are so critical of
us like
i couldn't believe not one person was
like does anyone else see claudia
blinking
seven thousand times i've never noticed
it but maybe i'm just because i'm always
looking at myself
very possible very possible so i'm gonna
work on
my arms and i'm not gonna work on my
blinking because i wouldn't know how to
work on it if i could but i could be
like ramona at new york fashion week
yeah deer and headlights i think what i
will work on if we're just talking about
working on things i'm gonna work on
being like a little less negative
okay that's always something great to
work on but i always say that and you
know being negative is just who i am
shouldn't i just embrace it yes and also
i do think
a lot of people tune in for the
negativity you know
it's so much easier to be negative no
not even that it's just
we're not unnecessarily negative no no
no no no so i do think
some stories require a bit of negativity
yeah and you know what it's like
no offense but like this is a comedy
show and being positive like isn't
necessarily funny
yeah but i think in certain situations
like on your birthday you know that's
where
let's try and be positive that was a
hard day for me no but when we're
recapping a story about
amber taking a dumb who did something
negative let's be negative
somebody left one of the funniest
comments on our youtube being like i
cannot believe this episode wasn't
called
amber turd no i know and that's what
we'll call her from here on out now but
that's like mean
that's what you know what i mean you
know what's mean taking a [ __ ] in
someone else's bed and expecting someone
else to clean it up
so true that's so true that's me so we
have a fabulous show of course we're
gonna do the fast five and then we're
also gonna recap some tv that was on
last night which includes the real
housewives of new york city
and the 30 rock one time special that
was on nbc last night
um which was essentially just like a
60-minute commercial for peacock and nbc
and i loved every minute of it i know
that i think we differ on
how we felt about it i watched it with
zach and i think it was the single best
piece of
virtual content made in quarantine that
i've seen yet
i agree tech wise i also think it was
the best piece of branded content i'd
ever seen like yeah
it was essentially just a really really
really entertaining commercial for 60
minutes and it was
for 60 minutes it was 60 minutes oh i
thought you said it was a commercial for
16. sorry for an hour yeah
no also it was like the nbc
upfront so it was it was cool because it
was so b2c
but also b2b they're talking to their
advertisers
but it's on prime time right so it
really took us behind the scenes this
some of the shows look great i couldn't
tell what was parody and what was the
real show
um assuming law and order just the
paperwork was already apparent but is
young
rock a real show for sure cool um so we
will get into 30 rock even though we
pretty much just did it already
and real housewives during our tv recap
segment but before that
i think you think it's time really
something else to say oh i got a haircut
i know i was just gonna say i feel as
though you want to talk about the fact
that you got a haircut but you forgot
and this is the first time in like the
last five years where i got a haircut
and i didn't come home and cry
it looks stunning stunning it's
beautiful stunning and smart i hadn't
been to a salon in forever
and it was so i felt so it was a little
like nervous back on a salon
um but it was just me and the
hairdresser there was only two people in
the salon and
i wore a mask the whole time and she was
like crazy with the lysol so i felt fine
like
coping wise um and then it was just so
nice to get like my hair washed and like
scratching my scalp that's like my
favorite part of a massage is like when
they scratch your scalp um
and it was good i honestly i had a very
positive experience at the salon and
then when i left the salon because
usually like i get
home and i literally like start pulling
my hair like i want to cry and just like
shave my head um but no i feel really
positive about it i just got like a two
inch
trim with some layers and i feel
refreshed
love it i'm gonna get a haircut soon too
i'm gonna keep the length but
i want to do like a lot of layers
sometimes like and we're long-haired
galleys
but sometimes your hair reaches like
this maybe it grows by like a quarter of
an inch
and it takes you from like
boho coachella to like vagrant on the
street
oh i i look forward to reaching that
length
but i don't think i'm there yet but my
hair is getting
really long but it needs now to be
embodied
but what's so crazy is like when i
filmed my special in january my hair was
so short
i remember it's been a long time since
then oh i guess yeah it feels like
literally last week yeah because again
just another great reminder to order my
comedy special disgraced queen available
on apple tv
itunes amazon prime so many places you
can stream buy and rent
the comedy special and the comedy album
yes you can listen to it it's like like
you do podcasts
so fabulous there's a highlight on my
instagram story it's called disgraced
queen
check it out all the links are there
it's it's beautiful if your boyfriend
plays
playstation i think you can actually
watch my comedy special i'm getting
confused between xbox or playstation but
one of them you could buy movies on and
you could buy my special on that one
got it i don't know which one it is
either and i got a bunch of dms and you
told me you did too
our episode of say yes to the dress is
airing like literally right now
as we speak and i'm just i'm really
looking forward to the nasty dms like
that's what gets me through
i haven't watched that episode in a
while i watched it soon
i watched it literally once when it came
out and i was so disgusted that i never
watched it again i'm sure it's probably
cute because we've gotten like really
nice
yes feedback feedback in the years since
it's been so long it's been
you know it's been mixed feedback but it
always is
it always is okay i think it's time to
get right into it the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
but wait jacks it's friday and we gotta
get down on friday
and what also we have to do is something
we've been doing for a few weeks now we
hope you guys have been enjoying it as
we are highlighting black owned
businesses and today's business is
fabulous
jam and rico founded by lizette scott in
2016
jamin rico is a caribbean inspired
fashion jewelry company providing bold
unique and colorful designs
growing up lizette was always influenced
by her culture with immigrant
grandparents from both islands
jamaica and puerto rico she was always
curious about their upbringing and
traditions that were formed from their
homeland
the most prominent inspirations were
food and music in her home
a little salsa and reggae with a mix of
a rose con poyo jerk and curry were her
favorites and loved within her home
once lizette got older and was able to
travel both sides of the island
the fascination and love of her heritage
grew even stronger
the colors carnivals art beaches and
language all inspired her to create and
design
that's when she knew she needed to
design she needed to design to bring her
closer to the cultural connection
of her ancestors lizette created jam and
rico
to dive deeper into her love of
designing and the caribbean
some of the most beautiful jewelry is so
colorful you guys are gonna love it if
you want to shop
jam enrico or just learn more about
lizette and the brand visit
jameandrico.com so that's
j-a-m-a-n-d-r-i-c-o
or you can find them on instagram
spelled the same at jam enrico
check it out really beautiful jewelry
beautiful colors you guys are gonna love
it
check it out love it okay let's get into
our first
story there's there's some good stories
today okay former ellen degeneres show
employees claim they were subject to a
toxic work environment
one current and ten former employees of
the ellen degeneres
show have come forward anonymously with
claims regarding a toxic work
environment on set
the individuals who spoke on the
condition of anonymity out of fear of
retribution
told buzzfeed news in a piece published
thursday that ellen degeneres is
epinomous
eponamus
ellen degeneres's tv show her yeah the
show that bears her name
um isn't the cheery benevolent program
viewers you see at home
instead employees said they were fired
after taking medical leave or
bereavement days
faced microaggressions and were
subjected to favoritism
by executive producers no specific
claims were made against degeneres
however some told buzzfeed news they
were not
to speak to the a-lister if she was in
the office quote people focus on rumors
about how ellen is mean and everything
like that but that's not the problem one
former employee claimed
the issue is these three executive
producers running the show
who are in charge of all these people
and who make the culture and are putting
out this feeling of bullying and being
mean
they feel that everybody who works at
the ellen show is so lucky to work there
quote so if you have a problem you
should leave because we'll hire someone
else because everybody wants to work
here
executives executive producers ed glavin
mary connolly and andy lassner told
enews that they are taking the claims
about themselves they are the three
executive producers
in question the claims we're taking the
self claims
yeah they're taking the claims about
themselves very seriously they added in
a statement we are truly heartbroken and
sorry to learn that even one person in
our production family
has had a negative experience it's not
who we are um
it clearly is note sounds like it's
exactly who you are and not who we
strive to be
this makes a lot of sense like because
there's always been like rumors about
ellen but at the end of the day
the ellen tv show probably has what like
200 people working on it from like tech
to producers to writers
that like it's the odds that ellen
actually like interacts
or um that any many of them would even
have experiences directly with ellen is
kind of rare because she is such a big
star and we know that she's
likes to keep to herself so it does make
sense that like this toxic culture isn't
being perpetuated by ellen she doesn't
really
work there she like does the show and
leaves you know so it seems like you
know these three executive producers
like
they feel cool like they're back in high
school and they're like in charge and
they want to
make everyone they're like the cool
jocks you know yeah and i think because
from what we've heard ellen has this
like
favoritism that she engages in with
among her staffers and i'm sure
the three people who are her favorites
the executive producers do the same
thing to the rest of the employees yeah
it might be the tone that ellen says but
she's not the one
i don't think she has the time i don't
think she hangs around i think she does
her show
for the hour she probably meets with the
producers they tell her what show she's
going to do
but the people who actually make the
show happen are the ones who work with
the
executive producers and not directly
with ellen yeah i mean it makes sense
because ellen's doing her show from home
right yeah and andy's like on the show
haha like standing outside her house in
the backyard
being like a comedian i don't know um i
don't watch
but i've seen videos he like stands
outside it's like supposed to be a funny
stick but i guess that was the best
the writers could come up with um so
yeah i mean we've been speaking about
this for a while there have been so many
um like rumors and just people sharing
their experiences
of either working for ellen with ellen
on the ellen show and it's just always
been like a negative experience
in the sense that it's just not like a
warm welcoming fun environment when it's
really like a comedy show
and it's also like a humanitarian show
like she gives away so much money she
does so much good work
it seems so strange that like what's
going on behind the walls of ellen would
literally be the polar opposite of what
her brand is it makes
no [ __ ] sense of what we see on the
show
so she ends every show and she says be
kind to one another and it's like
[ __ ] look at the [ __ ] mirror she
goes backstage and and this
toxic work environment is churning and
sweets it's like the irony is like so
poetic you know it really is
i think this combined with all of the
other
rumors about ellen throughout quarantine
um i think
they need to do a complete revamp like
of the back end of this show
i don't know i feel like you know what
ellen every time ellen renews first
season people are like oh we thought she
was like on
i feel like the end of ellen is upon us
like if she was young and like
had so many years ahead of her working
on ellen i think it would be worth it to
but i feel like she's over it and every
time she does it it's like a shock that
she renews for another season it's her
choice it's not like the network
her ratings are great i feel like this
is a terrible way to go out after like
such an accomplished career
and she needs to find a way to like
ease over all like the press and just
like go out gracefully
oh i disagree i don't think i think she
should keep doing her show i think her
show was great it clearly gets good
numbers people
whether what she does in her own
personal life it's her business
um she should be nice to people but
she's not
but i think the show does a lot of good
and and brings people a lot of joy
i i think they need to change the work
environment that surrounds it and
the executive producers who perpetuate
it has ellen even
acknowledged because she's still doing a
show right so it's like
a lot of these late night hosts are
coming under fire recently and they're
all going on vacation so like you don't
really get to hear from them but ellen
has been there's been during quarantine
like multiple reports about her and
she's still doing the show
and she doesn't even acknowledge it
which is so weird
yeah but hopefully she'll make some
changes whether she acknowledges it or
not hopefully she makes some changes
behind the scenes
because no one should have to work an
environment like this and what is shitty
feeling to feel like
oh you're so replaceable it's literally
devil wears prada a million dollar kill
for this job therefore i can treat you
like [ __ ] yeah no
it's terrible and i feel like if you're
a writer or you're into comedy like
working for or with ellen is probably
like
a goal and then you get there and it's
just like so shitty like a high school
yeah that sucks yeah that does suck
crazy well best of luck to those
executive producers i feel as though
time time might be up okay next story is
extremely sad
tamar braxton has been rushed to the
hospital after a possible overdose her
family is asking for prayers
tamar braxton is reportedly recovering
in the hospital after being found
unresponsive on wednesday
braxton is being monitored around the
clock as sources believe she made an
attempt to take her own life
nme reports she is currently in stable
condition
the singer and reality tv star had been
staying at the ritz carlton residences
in downtown l.a
with her partner david adefiso according
to the blast
when he found her unconscious he called
9-1-1 and reports suggests that braxton
has been drinking and appeared to have
consumed an unknown number of
prescription pills
oh man lapd confirmed to the outlet that
a call had been made around 9 45 pm
wednesday in regards to a quote possible
overdose by a woman matching braxton's
description well when i
heard the story this morning um it
didn't say that she was stable so i'm
glad that she is and this is just a
terrible story and just
it feels like a pylon like in a lot of
senses like all these terrible stories
coming out
um and i really hope that she is okay
and when she recovers she gets the help
that she needs
yeah because they're like they're like
so steeny they're so sister sister
sister so it's like
the family just must be like freaking
out like so sad so i really hope that
you know she can come to a full recovery
me too a spokesperson for the braxton
family released the following statement
quote tamar has had a very tough and
emotional day
more information will be coming in the
next few days please pray for her
and i think that's what we should all be
doing is sending our prayers
thoughts love and just holding out
hope for her sorry
agreed yeah no this is a terrible story
and i just
i can only imagine like what her sisters
are like freaking out about
and i just we're praying for her and i'm
glad that she's in stable condition and
i
am looking forward to her healing
process hopefully
yes definitely okay next story um
switching gears into a little random
celeb
couple question mark news i don't know
if you've heard this one yet let me hear
it because i heard it just this morning
colton underwood is dating lucy hale
keeping things close casual look at this
photo
i have so many things to say but here's
the t from tmz
t from tmz colton underwood has a new
woman in his life and it's lucy hale our
sources tell us the pretty little liars
actress
reached out to colton soon after his
split from ex-girlfriend cassie randolph
and the two have been seeing each other
a lot the ex-patcher went on a hike with
lucy wednesday
at post at paseo miramar trail in los
angeles
scenic pacific palisades neighborhood
sounds beautiful and as you can see
colton and lucy were pretty sweaty close
and without masks what oh well i think
that goes to say that like they've been
together without masks because you're
only like masculist with your quads but
they're outside
you're masculine with your quarantine
okay i don't want to get into that i
need to talk
i didn't know you're not here i'm not
here to talk about math i did not hear
about this
our sources say that colton and lucy
have gone on a few of these casual hike
dates over the last few weeks
so it seems their relationship has legs
lucy's had her eye on colton for years
too
back in 2018 she said he would make a
bachelor a good bachelor
because he's quote wholesome a good guy
and beautiful
to watch okay i think we all said that
back in 2018
yeah things have changed we're not
rumored to be dating um no the thing is
it's like usually um there it is call it
out
call it out oh the um and you were about
to speak so
it was like a fruitless um
i usually am a real champion of
celebrity relationships with someone
from the bachelor i feel like it
elevates the whole franchise like i
really
like i was here for tyler c and gigi not
at first but at last i love sarah
highland like i i really
usually can get on board but i really
don't like this and mostly due in fact
to the
due in part to the fact that like i just
i dislike colton and i
i have a special ability to like see him
for what he really is okay i'm just
going to remind you of a few things like
we spoke to colson at the cma red carpet
and he was
extremely nice yeah no by the way oh
sorry let me rephrase
i don't dislike him as a person i
thought he was lovely i just think he's
like a little thirsty
okay i don't know here's here's the
thing
one i do think it's a little soon
considering when he released his
statement with cassie for him to like
already be in a
new relationship the the thing here
though for me
is that i am obsessed with lucy hale
me too she i love everything she does
did you see the video she posted
recently because her show got canceled
so sad it was such a sad video talking
about how like
uh katie keane got cancelled and just
like
this industry just continues to break
her heart these shows that she loves
she has been in like three failed seas
series yeah
she did the one um life sentence life
sentence yes this and then i will never
forget
about privilege which was a show that
just meant so much to me so much justice
for privileged
and so i i just absolutely love her so
if she
she's one of these people who it's like
whatever she chooses to do with her life
like
i show up and i stand and i salute i
feel that i'm trying to now trace back
on like why i dislike this and
and i really i'm trying to figure it out
and i think part of me just dislikes
like
colton is obviously like thirsty for
fame like that's not
and so am i like i'm not saying that
like it's a bad thing but i think what
bothers me about him is that
he he gets where like all this press and
like all this
i don't know like these moments like off
the backs of women like at first it was
ali raisman then it was cassie and like
now it's lucy hill it's like do
something else
that's a really great point because you
know what now that i think about it yes
he has
his foundation but like his foundation
didn't make him famous ali raisman did
like he was a
he was a nobody football player and i
think when they dated like he actually
got dropped or whatever like it was he
had a very short-lived nfl career
and it's just like i don't know every
time i hear about him he's like he's
like no i mean
riding not like riding i mean like he's
riding another women woman like
to hollywood like yeah that's what
bothers me i just figured it out
you know it's helpful when you sit and
think about things before you say them i
should try it more often
i think that's a very fair point what
also bothers me about this story is this
photo which makes it clear that the
paparazzi were called
and of course the level of detail in
this article um
where it says that lucy's like reach out
to him makes it clear that
colton underwood called tmz himself set
up the photograph and then gave some tea
yeah and i that bothers me even though i
know that happens with celebrities
i need a little more subtlety in order
to just
go with it no yet being a part of pop
culture requires
a suspense of disbelief like we know
certain things are going on behind the
scenes
but we're going to pretend we'll all go
along like this real high now that every
time a celebrity gets paparazzi
they called them most of the time of the
time
um but i still like to think that
sometimes it's like the one time
running to starbucks you know when they
really were just like spotted
totally and i can i can suspend you know
and i could go along
and pretend for as much as possible but
this is so obvious
and i don't know there's just something
about it that bothers me
and i just wish colt like even with his
book like he sold the book
really being like you want to hear what
happened in the fantasy suite again like
trying to exploit cassie and then and
then people buy the book
and the chapter on the fantasy suite is
blank and it says
that's none of your business so it's
just like i feel like he keeps
i don't know there's something about it
that just doesn't feel right like so
much of
his career is just like
off the backs of women i hear that and i
just want to say sometimes i get this
gut feeling about a new couple
you know where i'm like this is it's the
end i'll be all this is not it and i can
tell you right now
this might be the last we actually ever
hear of it yeah i
think i think it might be that i do not
think that this is a love
match you know i could see something
happening where it's like lucy hale is
very famous she doesn't need to be like
calling
the paparazzi on herself um especially
like on a hike where she's like not
really doing anything
um and i feel like she might be put off
by like colton's obviously
like heavy-handedness in this situation
like she did this behind her back i
could see that being a situation
and even if you look at the body
language and this is still posted on our
instagram
is obviously like smiling like coy
looking directly at the camera and lucy
like looks like she's about to start
power walking away
yeah no and she's totally wearing
sunglasses like not interested if a body
language expert were to read this photo
they would agree with what i just said
that like this might be the end of it
just because
he called the paparazzi and he's
literally posing for the photo yeah and
i don't know if i was in a new real
relationship celebrity or not celebrity
and
my partner called the paparazzi like
date let's say it's date two date three
it's a little soon for me and on a hike
like give a girl some notice
no a hike is such an impact let's go
somewhere
fabulous yeah interesting i had not
heard about this but again
very interesting very interesting very
as i would say interesting
however whatever lucy chooses to do we
support we support
yeah next story some more unhappy couple
news
aaron rodgers and danica patrick break
up after two years of dating
oh yes oh my god i didn't hear that
either over for danica patrick and aaron
rodgers
they're quote no longer together a rep
for patrick told page six on thursday
rumblings of a split emerged first on
wednesday when swipe sports reported the
former nascar driver had unfollowed the
packers quarterback on instagram
patrick was also said to be a no-show at
a recent charity golf event that rogers
participated in
as of thursday he still follows her on
instagram
all right that's not like full-blown
proof but definitely something's up
let's say that they are broken up that
makes me really sad i don't know rep for
her confirming page six that they are no
longer together oh okay
um i'm like kind of sad about this i
actually really liked them and
when him him and olivia munn what
remember you probably don't remember no
of course not but remember when
i think it was i don't even know if it
was during olivia munn times or daddy
patrick because it was like probably
three years ago maybe even on the breath
where they went to a restaurant
yes of course they called the chives yes
and we said it sounded fabulous and we
wanted to move and go to the chat with
peter krause
um so i actually really liked this
couple because when he broke up with
olivia munn i was like
by the way the chive when we were
reporting on it sorry it was like their
first outing
yeah so we were like we reported on it
because we were so upset about him and
olivia munn breaking up and then we just
got all sidetracked with the concept
this chive sounds like a fabulous
restaurant
it still does by the way we should still
go so
back to what i've been trying to say
three times now when him and olivia munn
broke up i was really devastated because
i felt like
the breguets in their family had a lot
to do with aaron and
that was during the time when jordan and
jojo and i just like hated that aaron
and olivia broke up because it made it
look like jordan and jojo like somehow
won
do you know what i mean yeah and then he
started dating this danica girl who i'd
never heard of but i was like living for
it you haven't go daddy commercials
no i don't know what she's she's on the
go daddy commercial she's a nascar
driver
no i know i know that but she she's on
commercials when they started dating i
didn't know her
did you yes liar yes liar
no i i totally did whatever all i'm
saying was that like this
this rebound like ended up being like a
really good nice strong relationship
like
every time i heard about them i'm like
oh they're still together i love that
and now like i'm like oh they're still
together and you're saying no
so i'm i'm sad i'm sad too
i really am it's really hard not to talk
about them and not talk about
jojo and jordan what do you mean it's
impossible it's impossible and
with every breakup i'm like maybe he'll
call his family well so now i'm like you
know maybe he'll be really lonely and
lonely enough desperate enough to get in
contact with his family
yeah apparently he's apparently dating
shaylene what
are your sources to say where is that we
saw it on nessin i don't know what that
is
um that's interesting uh okay i'm here
for it i actually really like shailene
woodley me too
she's you know she's different i heard
she like gave up all of her early
possessions and she like lives on a farm
and doesn't
have a cell phone so i don't know if she
would be like going to football games in
wisconsin
but a girl can dream opposites attract
opposites attract that's why you and i
are such best friends
see look she won't touch me okay um
i hope that that's true about aaron and
shaylene and i hope danica finds love
as well sad to see these two break up
but again i didn't get that warm fuzzy
um
this is it feeling in my stomach i
didn't you know what i did
not get it i got the feeling of this is
good yeah but not
this is it who do you have the warm
fuzzy feeling for about this is it like
um
i feel like we're always we were talking
about um
billy lord and her like nobody boyfriend
yeah yeah
but also like david foster catherine
mcphee yeah um
we were talking about machine gun kelly
megan fox yes
we were talking about vinnie and
francesco morocco i don't get that warm
fuzzy feeling
either but i get like a a toddred love
affair yes
and then also lily james and one of the
christmases i don't think i got that
feeling
no i didn't either it's too soon yeah
okay fifth and final story a little
exciting rob kardashian news because he
wait no no
isn't it the fifth and final news that's
brought to you by patreon.com morning
toast
it is this story is brought to you by
our patreon
channel patreon.com morning toast where
we give you
five extra bonus episodes of the toast
every month but they're not really toast
episodes they're more personal they're
vlogs
they're topical so you get five episodes
some of them are videos some of them are
audio episodes like regular podcasts
for the podcast we'll do like topical so
we did a whole episode this week on
conspiracy theories we did a whole
episode on like what
plastic surgery beauty cosmetic
procedures we've had done
um we've done a whole episode on judaism
uh
really topical stuff and then our vlogs
are more behind the scenes more family
stuff
um with all the scenes with ben we're
doing a chili cook-off i think next
month we're trying to figure out the
logistics of the chili cook-off
um so yeah it's 7.99 a month it's a
great way to support the show and then
also get five extra episodes
and they're behind a paywall so i think
we both feel a little bit more
comfortable like
opening opening up because it's it's
just a little bit more protected and our
episode with nt
is actually behind the paywall so when
you when you sign up for
patreon again it's 7.99 access to like
all the old episodes let me share with
you some
episodes that we've done we just did
conspiracy theories we did two episodes
about real housewives
tagline history and we just talked about
real housewives in depth and all the
moments that happened on that show
before we started doing our show
we do general q and a's where if you're
in the toast after dark which you should
subscribe membership is up to date
so join toast after dark if you're a
patron you've been waiting to get in
join now because we are doing membership
we did an episode about our favorite
things in every category what we're
loving streaming watching
eating drinking we did an episode
that's gni in the queue i had claudia
over at my house we made a pizza we got
drunk it's [ __ ] hilarious it's a
vlog we did a zoom get ready with us one
morning where we each got ready together
on zoom
we did a zoom like happy hour with all
the sisters that was like a crowd
favorite
yes we did that as well we did a
faux interview where a girl with no job
gets a job
people love that that was so mad i
forgot about that one that one was so
funny jackie sat down and like asked me
all the classic
job interview questions and um i don't
know i never really had a job before it
was
so funny we did but each of us did a
vlog of our day in the life in
quarantine what we were doing in a day
that was fun
we have cooking videos shows with
olivia and ben and margo we do
interviews with our husbands
i have my house tour up there it took me
nine months but
my house scores up there too and so is
olivia's so yeah if you if you buy a
subscription now you get access like
over 200 episodes so it's really a
fabulous deal
yes oh my god we did two episodes wow i
forgot about this where we debriefed
all of the toast guests all of the
guests that have ever come on the show
we went through all of our episodes and
we talked about every guest in our
experience
having them on the show and behind the
scenes and any tea that they might have
spilled i did an anniversary episode
with zach we do a lot of djt
recaps i mean there's toast radio which
is one of our most controversial
segments
it's a controversial series um in the
patreon it's one of my favorites because
it was my idea it's basically like
jackie and i being radio host where it's
like we talk about music and then we
play a song you know
yeah um some people don't like it also
um you also get access to i think
one of the most well received videos
we've ever done which was our drunk get
ready with us
oh when we went to the the squeeze
freeze concert
we got drunk and we did our makeup for
the concert and it was in the vein of
kylie and chloe's video and it was
i think ours was better i think it was
too for sure so head over to patreon.com
morning toast if you want some premium
content and or you just want to support
this show
fifth and final story rob kardashian
returning to kardashians he's returning
to kardashians
rob stepped away from his famous
family's e-reality tv series a few years
ago as he struggled with waking and
depression but is ready to come back in
a more
full-time capacity chloe revealed on
siriusxm's the morning mashup
quote my brother's coming back around
he's feeling more confident and
comfortable
i think he just you know started a whole
new season the usually recruit
reclusive rob made a cameo on an episode
earlier this year to celebrate daughter
dream's birthday
but i guess according to chloe we'll be
getting more rob wow that's exciting i
mean i kind of expected rob to never
come back
i wasn't like waiting patiently for him
like i really understood
that the show was toxic for him and he
was in a bad place and i
i totally like understood and respected
that and i never expected him to come
back
but this was just kind of like sprung on
me and i'm so excited
yeah i'm i'm really excited and mostly
i'm glad to hear that he's doing well
enough
to feel like he wants to come back to
the show you know it's
it's it's one thing to like struggle
with depression and have to go back to
work
but it's another thing to struggle with
depression and have to go back to work
when your work is like such a public
platform and you're
clearly like have struggled with your
weight and
i could see how it's like this perfect
storm of just like toxicity
and i really never thought he was gonna
return and i love watching old episodes
with him and i love him he's one of my
favorites and
we are running out of kardashians
because like kylie's never on courtney
quit kendall like barely comes on
it's really just chloe kim and chris
putting the entire show on their back so
we logistically like we need more cast
members we do need more cast members so
this is good for the show
it's good for rob and it's good for the
content i'm excited
i think that means he'll be getting a
check which is just good for dream i
think he's been getting paid
but i think that family deal the 100
million i think that
they cut him into you know what's so
interesting is that like we're still
in that hundred million do you remember
years ago i remember was on the cover of
the new york post
when they got there after like 10 or so
seasons they renegotiated
renegotiated their deal with e for
another 10th season and it was 100
million dollars for the family
and now like given like how far they've
come like it doesn't seem like enough
no it doesn't seem like enough because
when you split it and does that mean
chris gets
part of the 100 million and then 10
percent of everyone else's i think she
gets 10
of the 100 million right so um i feel
like they definitely split it equally
because they're
they're that type of family and it would
create so much
weird weirdness and hierarchy if it was
divvied up
in equally and the way that kim and
chloe talk on the show about everyone
contributing they're talking as if
they're all getting paid equally because
if they were getting paid more
they wouldn't say the things that they
were saying because that's fair right
but kim keeps saying like it needs to be
fair but i think that's because it's
split equally except i don't think that
kylie jenner came from the show because
i don't think she needs the money like
because she's actually not on it like
kendall is on it
yeah she's on it she doesn't want to be
on it she doesn't need the money but i
do think rob gets
yeah and also like chris jenner took
arthur george and
while rob has been kind of on hiatus
she's churning out that content she's
always posting about it on her instagram
they have a thriving instagram they sell
them at neiman marcus
um so that must be like maybe like a
couple million dollars a year for uh
maybe less
i think less i don't know kris jenner
she's
everything of the sort she really is and
just seeing her on real housewives of
beverly hills last night
two nights ago confirmed that well that
is a great recap into
segway into our tv recap section it was
almost a great segway sorry [ __ ]
um and also this serves as a reminder
that next week on monday we're going to
recap our toast movie of the week
which is remember the titans so make
sure to check it out we'll be recapping
it on monday we hope you guys
participate with us but let's talk about
what we watched last night first up the
30 rock
one time special reunion on nbc i didn't
realize
i thought they were just like getting
together like for fun like it was
clearly
this really brilliant marketing tactic
to not only you know show the new slate
of content coming in for
nbc and nbc owns bravo e sci-fi usa so
it's not just like channel four
yeah it's all of nbc so to highlight all
the new shows they have coming and then
also to promote peacock which
um is out right yes it's totally french
like yesterday olivia called me she was
like you
have to download peacock i'm like really
she said it's totally free she was not
lying like
if you have cable you just log in with
your cable i know you don't have cable
you can use mine
um and she's like they have literally
every season of like random bravo shows
they have the rachel zoe project
oh my god so yeah it's i'm definitely
gonna download it also it's free so i
don't know why i wouldn't
yeah it's free and there's so much
content and i you said they've smashed
did you ever watch them no she texted me
last night asking me if i used to watch
she texted me too and i'm like no that
was margo like she literally couldn't
remember which sister watched snapchat
that is so funny i could
she didn't respond so i i didn't
remember that she texted me and i didn't
know why she asked me that right but now
i understand why peacock's just
taking over her life taking over her
life yes so i thought the 30 rock
special was a great
entree into peacock kevin uh no
what's his name tracy morgan no kenneth
kenneth paige oh my god that was so
head of the network it was just
perfection the fact that they have a
show about nbc the network
it just made perfect sense well by the
yeah the fact that 30 rock let's just
take it back the fact that 30 rock aired
on nbc and it was a show about nbc about
a show
like 30 about the 30 rock the building
in which they were and tgs was
essentially
the show oh i never thought of that yeah
um genius like that whole thing was
genius and the show was really
so brilliant we talk about it here all
the time like i've just
it was just a fabulous show and they won
so many enemies and they kind of you
know went out a little bit disgracefully
like they cut the last season and have
nobody was watching it
there was like five years in a row where
they won every single emmy and then like
it was over
yeah but i was thrilled to be hearing
that they would be
doing a reunion because like by the way
i don't even like liz lemon i think
she's so annoying
but i watch the show for one reason and
one reason only and that's tracy morgan
and as i was watching last night
i came to the realization like when
people ask me like who's your favorite
comedian i always say joan rivers and i
think now i need to say joan rivers and
tracy morgan
yeah he's incredible i also love jack
donaghy
and i love jenna there's something about
i absolutely love jenna when she was
singing the universal song
first of all it was an amazing song yeah
they did it so well
every zoom thing that we see is not only
bad quality
it's awkward the stories suck everything
about this was so well done it was so of
the moment
it was the best virtual content that's
been made in the last six months and
and everyone's been trying khloe
kardashian's cameo was so funny
i loved that they had all of these
different stars from the nbc family
it was
when chrisley said he was cousins with
kenneth todd chris he was like see you
later cousin
that was so funny it's so funny when
when um when liz lemon was like i saw
you on a show with andrew cohen i was
like who the [ __ ] is that
totally it was just it was so good the
references the cameos
everything about it was so well done
even the storyline was really good
and a perfect way to set up peacock i
was so impressed
and i'd spoken to you and you said that
the second half i wasn't going to like
no i said that i just like i was so in
awe in the beginning between everyone
coming and then like the quality was so
good
and then like the commercially vibe just
took over yes
but you know what i i liked the
commercially vibe i was watching with
zach and we were both like
this is so good we were so impressed all
along the way i thought it was the
perfect way to introduce peacock
a great 30 rock reunion which by the way
reunions happen all the time and they
suck so not only was it
a great reunion but they also like got
some business done
yeah it was effective it was effective
business
and consumerism and i think it's the
type of vertical integration that jack
donaghy would
be proud of so sure that was a great
little reference great way to tie it up
in a bow
um and then we finished the berkshires
last night in real housewives of new
york and it was actually a good episode
we're two for two this week with um
housewives let's take it back to the the
night where we left off
where um everyone is really drunk and i
think that
i forget because we haven't seen luanne
drunk in a few seasons that like
she was they used to joke that she had a
wooden leg like she
really could hold her own so i think
part of me didn't realize how [ __ ] up
she was when she was packing and
hysterically sobbing
and i had never seen her cry before when
the that
dinner where they are just nuts
if you listen if you were to listen to
it without looking at it
they sound like children like who are
like having
tantrums there's something so
strange about this season and and the
alcohol because usually in any season
we get like one crazy night you know
where everyone just
had a little too much to drink and
things get off the handle and then all
the fights for the rest of the season
ensue from that night
but this is so commonplace for the real
housewives of new york at this point
that the next day they're not even
fighting about the awful awful things
that were said well so
regardless of whose side you were on
with the luan and sonia debacle which i
actually have
thought about a lot okay let's get into
it see
i keep going back and forth because part
of me is like yeah luanne
what are you doing pay pay sonya but
part of me knows what it's like to run a
tour and i have a zero expense tour
because it's literally just
me on stage i have been to luann's show
multiple times she has a full band a
full set full decor like it is expensive
to not only travel
with the production but also have it set
up at every show so like i definitely
think
it looks like she's making more money
than she is and it's really her tour is
very successful
and part of me is like you know what i
think in a lot of ways she said it kind
of rudely
not that she's doing sonia a favor by
having her come on the tour but it's
like what luanne has built is really
really impressive and all of these women
have been trying for so long to like
none of them really have jobs
outside of housewives and they've all
been trying like with their weird merch
or like
they've been trying to like do something
and luanne really did it and i think in
a lot of ways
her giving sonja the opportunity to come
on the tour is a big it's a big
opportunity for sonia like if it was
popular enough
sonia could go on her own tour like it
is the stepping stone so i think getting
so caught up in the money where it's
like luanne's like you're not even
valuing the fact that i'm letting you
come on my tour like yes sonia is
fabulous and she would do amazing but
luanne's tour is successful
on its own without sonia so i kind of
understood why she's like please
first of all don't get involved the
other women it's like annoying and it's
like no one's even acknowledging
the opportunity like the gift that luann
is giving sonia
i hear what you're saying um i think
ramona actually said it best when she
said that
sonja is like the butt of the joke on
this
show on the tour and she's not even
paying her
yeah and i agree you know it is a
platform it is an opportunity but sonia
also brings eyeballs people love sonia
and it becomes more of a real housewives
fan thing versus just like
an actual cabaret show yeah also if
you were doing the dirty jean store and
you were bringing me out on certain
shows and
embarrassing me and i was and and i was
just part of the joke and i was a part
of a stick for you
i would demand to be paid and you would
pay me yes of course no but see
i feel like it's if we're selling a show
jackie and claudia let me split it like
of course so but no say it's dirty jeans
okay and there's a few shows where like
i'm coming we're doing like a bit
together
actually i don't know but you're my
sister so i wouldn't i know but like i
would pay you but
i wouldn't pay 250 so i would be like
four figures
right that and that's what the girls are
saying they're saying that and i'm sure
luanne brags about how much money she's
making from before
and then you see what sonya is making
she'd be better off not paying sonia at
all and just arguing that it's
about the experience and the experience
for her versus valuing her at 250
that's very true but you know the
conversation becomes irrelevant when
dorinda gets up
in an attempt to somehow defend sonia
who she thinks she needs to protect
and just becomes evil and i was
surprised when luanne woke up the next
morning and wasn't still upset because
exactly what dorinda said to make luanne
cry is exactly what she said
in mexico two years ago that literally
caused a break in their friendship for
over a year at least i don't have a
mug shot she brought up the mug shot
again and that like totally devastated
luanne when she said it the first time
so this is where i was at last night in
the argument between luanne and sonia i
had sonya i i agreed with sonia and i
think that luanne should respect her and
pay her more
the way that dorinda treated luanne in
an argument that had nothing to do with
her inder in his own home making her
feel unwelcome saying horrible things
about her
made me take luanne's side when she left
i was like i would leave too i'm like
get in the car you're never gonna leave
if you don't get in the [ __ ] car no i
thought for sure
you can't stay there they were being so
rude to her and dorinda is supposed to
be a host you can't just go off on your
guests like that
especially when this has nothing to do
with you i thought sonia was
i mean she was so so drunk and by the
way does she own another sweater
she's wearing the same sweater in the
car at dinner all night woke up in it
yeah she obviously wore it that night
slept in it just kept going um and i
thought that ramona was doing a good job
of having sonia's back so it was not for
jorinda
to step in nope and make her guest feel
uncomfortable ramon is a perfect example
of like okay you want to take up for
sonia sure you have to insult luanne
actually i was really shocked ramona was
like really
she was drinking but she was not visibly
drunk at any point and she was really
being
weirdly the voice of reason i agree and
she continues to be i feel like she
had some sort of moment last year after
last season where she decided she's
going to be above the fray now and like
she doesn't want to get
involved and that's why i think next
week when we see all the girls like
gyrating at her birthday party with her
fancy friends like
ramona has now decided she doesn't care
about what she's done in the past she is
now above
a certain line and she won't go below it
interesting
also ramona really was the voice of
reason because she had sonia's back and
in the argument where i do think sonia
was justified justified but then when
luanne was upset she went out and she
went out with leah and luanne
and she was there for louis was on the
right side i think she really was there
for both of her friends at that time i
agree
there's something else i want to talk
about because we posted on our instagram
this cameo
yes of elise and leah who are obviously
like i guess
hanging out quarantining together i
don't know um
interesting factoid but after this
week's episode i'm like oh they
obviously develop a friendship because
they were like making out and they're
obviously like becoming friends
yes which is cute i love when people
become friends off the show and
spending time together even though
they're not being filmed but elise made
a cameo as you do wishing someone a
happy birthday um
started out weird like just started out
awkward and then
leah comes in they talk about ramona and
then leah said that the reason that
ramona can't keep a man
is because she shits the bed every time
she has sex
which um i actually really did not like
that was
kind of like way below the belt which is
exactly what everyone's been saying
about dorinda like
so you can't you can't complain about
what jordin does and then like you
literally are doing the same exact thing
yeah well it's interesting because
during the called leah like a mini
dorinda
what an insult what an insult i do not
think that's true
but that cameo i i didn't live for it i
saw a lot of comments like oh my god
living leah's the queen
i thought it was really [ __ ] rude it
brought me the wrong way unnecessary and
gross and what i need to see what ramona
did to leah to
to make that they've been beefing
hardcore
on social media that thing about
hurricane leah and
about ramona and then like avery was
like posting videos of leah like being
drunken and talking and being like hey
mom i can't believe you associate with
this
and then leah was like like literally
coming for avery and they've just been
and now ramona's been like under fire
because she has been like traveling from
palm beach to the hamptons like not
really being
super um careful when it comes to coven
and then she said she had antibodies and
then she went to that party in the
hamptons at your final house where a
bunch of people got coronavirus
and leah has kind of been like attacking
her on that front now so they are
not getting along like that their
whatever is going to be unpacked at the
reunion which i heard is being filmed
very soon they filmed beverly hills
yesterday
virtually i don't know garcelle kept
tweeting like reunion
and i saw her in glam but it just like
looked like glam i don't know if it was
[ __ ] i need to know i'm down for a
virtual reunion i think that they've
turned out fine
nbc obviously has their zoom priorities
in order i need to see the full looks
like it's just it's not the same
but what can you do leah bringing that
bartender
oh my god i thought that was so cute so
here's the thing
i love leah i think she's an amazing
housewife i don't think any housewife
has had a better first impression than
her
i did not like the video initiating the
bad thing it
it just rubbed me the wrong way grabbed
me
it's a really disrespectful thing to say
about anyone let alone like a
a mature woman an older woman mature
um and then what else happened at that
dinner party with colin cowie like
dorinda bothers me so much like i don't
know i just
everything about her is just like so
like i'm not impressed by anything she
does i'm like wow colin cowie making a
salad with a scissor like who [ __ ]
cares
yeah it was just so i actually like her
sister though
melinda melinda once a year we
get a glimpse of jordana's sister who i
just need to know more about it's crazy
she looks so much like dorinda yeah but
her name's
melinda and it's fabulous oh actually
heather that party i was going to say
that party looked really really fun
they never opened up the berkshires the
berkshires it's like they're always
literally in the shining like nobody
comes in and out of the house but they
went shopping and now people are coming
over for dinner i actually liked this
version better
no because the house is now open it's
like
in like i just read this book about a
haunted house and like they had to like
expunge
it was also like spooky and um like
hocus pocusing okay
but uh that now that the house is
haunted actually
no spoilers but whatever some get to it
it's unhaunted now so yes people can
come in and out and like and that's
blue and that's what she was saying last
week and even sonia said like pulling up
to this house like i like this house now
whereas before i never did yeah i get
that there's something fresh about it
and the party looks so fun i love seeing
heather i actually really liked her i
always liked it i
love her she was just a good girl she
has like a good marriage and a good
business and i just think she was like a
good person i really like her yeah
i i really like her in the show didn't
let you know [ __ ] all over her yeah
and then we had um i think it was a gay
couple that one of them got seated next
to ramona and ramona was talking about
how
um all she cares about is really like
finding a man with money and this guy
had like such a fresh normal perspective
she's ramona was like i need someone who
has as much money as me and i guess like
okay but then the guy was like why it's
like there's literally
so few guys like that and don't you just
want like a nice guy who loves you who
love you it's like ramona's accomplished
she has two homes right she has two
residences and
she travels a lot but here's the thing
since if ramona has so much money so
then why does she need a man who has
money right you know
i don't think ramona has so much money i
think she says that she
i think she has a like she lives a very
good life i do believe she
has her home in the hamptons she sold
her apartment in new york and i believe
she rents now so it's just
i think when at the height of her and
mario's career i think that they lived a
very affluent life but i think with the
divorce and just like
ramona used to have businesses and she
doesn't anymore like the housewife is
i think she lives a very good life but i
don't think it's the life
that she level that she wants to be at
and i don't think it's a level that a
lot of her fancy friends are at
yeah and i think she's looking for a man
to elevate her to that level with the
women who were at the
the gala where she said don't invite
tonya to my birthday party got it okay
that makes complete sense that's what i
think but yeah she lives a
very good quality of life i'm not saying
anything
um but also i didn't like the way ramona
spoke about sonya like if sonya needs
the money
like it's just ramona is getting
much better but the way she talks about
money it's like girl get some
self-awareness come on
i agree it's a little cringy too it is
extremely cringy
and you know what i really don't miss
tinsley like at all no me neither
because she was an easy punching bag for
so many of the women
and i think a lot of people just like
when they wanted to lash out they just
went to her and it wasn't a fair fight
and
it's not it's i'm not even interesting
but when it's during the verse luanne
it's like
[ __ ] yeah what's the man gonna say back
right you know if it's dorinda versus
ramona even like
it's it's equal but with tinsley
she just didn't have the chops for it
and you know what i think that's fine
because i don't think
most people are equipped for the level
of insanity that goes down on the real
house side of new york
no but the episode like them in the
berkshires just like one of me
made me so badly want to like rent a
cabin upstairs and like invite a bunch
of friends like
the way they all just like got dressed
up to like sit around the fire and have
like a catered dinner like sounds like
the ideal night i can't wait for the
fall
i can't wait for the fall it was it was
really a bucolic episode
truly um so yeah that is our show we
hope you guys enjoyed all the episodes
this week
if you want to catch up on any of them
they're all available on youtube for the
video and the videos are also now
available on spotify so if you are
already a podcast listener listening on
spotify
you can now catch the videos on there
but the podcast audios are still
everywhere you can find them
spotify itunes stitcher public radio you
know what you know what it is you guys
you know the drill but wherever you
listen to podcasts please find us the
morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
over the weekend if you're looking for
something to do i would highly recommend
renting or streaming
my comedy special it is available on
multiple platforms if you go to the
instagram highlight on girl with no job
called disgraced queen
all the links to stream purchase rent
all the stuff so
i really appreciate the support and
thanks for tagging me on all your
instagram stories
um if you take any pictures this weekend
make sure they look fire as
[ __ ] using jackie o'flow jackie's
presets from jackie o'flow
jackieoflo.com
and that's all she wrote that is all
shira we will see you on monday goodbye
you